I don't want welcome to this video play
if I'm drunken drunken night who is that
Chris Duncan from London ok so I get
this transposition to a chiro ya hear
hmm caretaking will probably transpose
anyway let's do it queen bee three is
now the most no okay yeah yeah I feel
reasonably comfortable let's see can i
play for this blockade on the light
squares iam so Dwight ambitious mighty
fried fish should be 60 it just gives me
this bishop okay thanks happy to take it
yeah i mean this pawn structure has
improved but i'm happy to get get the
payoff bishops um I mean he has probably
always be should be fired if you just
wants to trade one so it's not a huge
deal of course so I'm here and then
Queen to f5 that looks okay here right I
mean if he moves the bishop I can take a
3 n term worsen his pawn structure
considerably yeah let's do it
so hope the eight what is the best way
to play it and probably work the
eight-point structure wise i am slightly
better here with this double porn but is
it possible to really do something here
not that easy actually i wonder if i
should play up sex i will do that to
actually make this pawn stay on d4 so
looking actually at first a Tekkit and
then only later get at five and I no f5
so he's attacking a seven in return I
can go a five but probably it will go
deep no we cannot go to five so i
probably should do this then
probably hook t1 back now for him not
backward that's a look okay so that's
why if I was possible in the first place
to d5 why was I the d5 was prevented
yeah okay not a long game in the opening
mid section on in the opening here this
is not so popular and normally while
plays this move looking at this I cannot
save this night usually black place like
this which leads to an interesting yeah
unbalanced game he would black having a
bad structure but to bishops yeah this
is a bit uncommon but obviously it
cannot be a bad work was cancelled
cancelled 95 yeah that was a plant to
play like this and then possibly here
and here when the engine things equal
that probably probably correct yeah okay
I'm happy with the bishop pair even
though it's not probably giving me some
some advantage he has a good center and
active pieces so I don't think something
special is going on here the engine
gives equal which is certainly fair yeah
be should be five I probably would have
done that and now I went for for this
thing which which again I think it's not
really doing all that much like here the
a slight edge from black maybe add you
to the pawn structure I should be a bit
better but it's not it's nothing special
yeah f6 debatable but i think it's not a
bad idea first pile up on this pawn and
then player 5
this five think everything's still kind
of normal and now you play this is t
five more I thought just drooped in one
back and it should be okay for white
it's quite difficult ear for black to
make any sort of headway and you cannot
easily push pause like 85 is bad be five
it it looks like I'm the active party
attacking this porn it is defending that
it's not much going on I think it's
roughly equal the engine yeah this is
basically agreeing the line that it
gives us something some trades going on
Rupert e6 gap equal is probably right
but not after he gave up the rook ok
guys thanks for watching